well this week saw Boris Johnson's 8th
parliamentary defeat as Prime Minister
and David Gorkhas one of the 21 former
Conservative MP stripped to the whip for
voting against him and the former
justice secretary is starting to make a
bit of a habit of rebelling he joins us
now from his constituency in
hartfordshire thank you for being with
us and first of all we're here at
concept in party confidence you voted
against allowing a short recess in order
for it to go ahead is that not a bit an
insult to the activists who've spent a
lot of money coming here no because it's
perfectly possible to carry on with
conference and that's exactly what's
happening and conferences carrying on
ministers will be there I will be going
to conference this afternoon so the two
can carry on but I think it is important
given that Parliament hadn't been
sitting for a number of days as it
turned out unlawfully that we make use
of the time available that Parliament is
able to carry on and do its work so I
think it's right that both the
conference goes ahead and that
Parliament continues to sit and now you
said that Boris Johnson is borrowing
from in your words the Donald Trump
playbook are you worried about the
direction that your party is going in
yes I am worried about the direction the
conservative party is going in at the
moment I think there is a choice for us
we can return to our traditions of being
a broad church a party that is
responsible that is competent that looks
to unite the country as much as possible
or we can take an approach whereby we
seek to divide the country that we call
sin our language that we only seek to
appeal to a particular part of society
and we demonize the rest that we
undermine our institutions and there are
aspects of what has been happening in
recent weeks that I fear fall into that
second category and it does remind me of
the way that Donald Trump is now running
the Republican Party in the u.s. I think
that is a a disappointing state of
affairs to put it mildly I don't believe
that's right for the Conservative Party
I don't believe it's right for the
country and I hope that we see a change
of direction in the course of the next
few days at the Conservative Party
conference
I think it's interesting that trumpian
is almost used as an insult there are a
lot of people obviously in America who
voted for Donald Trump is it's not just
a bit of a pejorative way of talking
about people whose opinions you don't
really like well look I think the
conservative party should aim higher
than the standards of Donald Trump that
the approach that he takes to politics
the approach that he takes to
truth-telling
the approach that he takes in terms of
dividing his country is not something
that I want to see in the United Kingdom
and it's certainly not something that I
want to see from the party I've been a
member of for 29 years so I I make no
apology for criticizing the Donald Trump
style of politics it's not what I want
to see from the Conservative Party and I
think never mind bad for the country
that's really important but if that's
the approach that we go for the
Conservative Party will be waving
goodbye to millions of its long-standing
supporters and at a time when MPs are
concerned for their safety there's been
a lot of focus in Parliament this week
about the language and that our
politicians are using in particular of
course number 10 and also the prime
minister talking about the surrender act
talking about humiliation saying we will
not betray the people are you worried
about some of that language and do you
think that in the words of amber Raddatz
inciting violence I am worried about the
use of language at the moment it is
incredibly divisive it is designed to
stoke resentment to provoke anger to
nurse grievances and it is feeding into
a toxic toxic atmosphere not just in
Parliament but I think more widely I
think we have to recognize that people
can take different views on the issue of
brexit but hold those views in good
faith and I think this applies to all
sides because I think there's you know
one side has had a tendency to sneer the
other side has had a tendency to
denigrate and accuse people of being
unpatriotic
got to recognize that people of good
faith and intelligence can hold
different views on this matter and that
ultimately as a country we've got to
come back together again at some point
we heard from at Hancock earlier the
health secretary who was defending the
use of the word those surrender acting
said it's actually is you know an
accurate way of describing what the ban
acts thinks to do when it is of course
when we talk about these things and just
for the viewers you know it's it's the
the idea that MPs voted to compel the
Prime Minister to seek an extension
rather than leave with no deal if you
can't get a deal with the EU now there's
a story in the mail on sunday today
saying that people involved in the
drafting of that act got help from
Brussels you were very close to what
happened with that act is that true no
it's not true
and I think here is a very good example
of a number-10 briefing using the word
collusion I mean that's a very loaded
word in itself collusion providing no
evidence that there was anything
supporting this statement that there was
help with the drafting coming from
foreign countries it's not true but even
if it were true the use of language of
that sort is completely disproportionate
completely over the top and feeds into
this narrative there anyone who doesn't
agree with number Ten's position is
somehow unpatriotic or betraying the
country or an enemy or wanting the
country to surrender I mean this is the
sort of language that I think a lot of
people are concerned about because it is
questioning motives of people who are
just trying to do the best for this
country and avoid what most people I
think who've studied this closely would
accept would be a disastrous outcome of
us leaving without a deal on the 31st of
October causing great damage to our
prosperity and the integrity of the
United Kingdom is it right that there
are plans to try and look at a second
piece of legislation that would
effectively allow the speaker to bypass
the prime minister to request an
extension if necessary
well I don't wanna get drawn into
specific and ideas but what I would say
is that the Ben Act is effective it does
what it intends to do and it should be
abided by and I very much hope that the
government will be clear that they will
abide by the law and you know there are
lots of suggestions of loopholes and so
on as far as I can see anything that's
being suggested so far it can be easily
dealt with and if necessary the courts
will ensure that the will of Parliament
and the law is complied with it's
interesting you say that mean what do
you think the consequences would be if
Downing Street if the Prime Minister did
try to ignore the Ben Act well in truth
if there's an attempt to not follow the
law then the law will take its course
and it'll be a question of going to the
courts and the court will ensure that
the law is complied with but we are a
country that is governed by laws that is
our history that is our tradition is one
of the most important things about the
United Kingdom and the Prime Minister to
be fair has been clear that he's going
to abide by the law but to suggest
otherwise these sort of hints that all
somehow we're not going to do that I
think is is dangerous it undermines the
rule of law in this country and that's
not the role of government to do far
from it and then just finally you of
course have had the Conservative whip
withdrawn for voting against the
government and previously I'm interested
to know what your next steps are what
your plans are do you want to be
readmitted to the Conservative Party you
want to run as an independent where are
you looking at what what are your plans
what's your thoughts well look I
consider myself a conservative I've been
a member of the Conservative Party for
29 years the first time I rebelled
against the conservative whip after 14
years as an MP I had the whip withdrawn
I would like to fight the next general
election in my constituency southwest
half for chair as the Conservative
candidate but it's obviously not
entirely within my control if I can't do
that
obviously consider my options but as far
as I'm concerned I consider myself a
conservative I think my views are
consistent with the best traditions of
the Conservative Party and I think
represent the views of many conservative
voters
okay David Gork thank you very much for
being on the program today thank you